okay hillary clinton we've heard from
hillary clinton hillary clinton
says uh that joe biden should not
concede the election
to donald trump in the immediate
aftermath of november 3rd
under any circumstances until and if it
becomes clear
that joe biden has actually lost the
election there's an
interesting new interview clinton was
interviewed by
jennifer palmieri for the showtime
program the circus
and right wingers are losing their minds
about what hillary said
sean hannity is feverishly tweeting
about it people are going crazy
it's really not a big deal actually what
hillary clinton says makes a lot of
sense
uh and in fact it shouldn't even be
super controversial let's take a look at
it then we'll discuss
so we've got to have a massive
legal operation i know the biden
campaign is working on that
we have to have poll workers and i urge
people
who are able to
be a poll worker we have to have
our own uh teams of people to counter
the
the force of intimidation that the
republicans and trump
are going to put outside polling places
this is a big organizational challenge
but at least we know
more about what they're going to do and
you know joe biden should not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is going to drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give an inch and if we are as
focused and relentless as the other side
is
so this is actually good advice and
democrats
democrats sometimes are pushovers let's
be completely frank
and there really is no incentive to
concede early period
now people like sean hannity and others
are pretending
that what hillary clinton is saying is
never concede no matter what even if you
lose the popular vote and the electoral
vote handily
and there's no foul play that appears to
have taken
place and there's no that's not what
hillary clinton is saying
hillary clinton is astutely pointing out
trump is not going to concede uh if it's
close
trump is going to claim that it's rigged
donald trump is
trying to rig it and planning to rig it
so
why should joe biden concede if there's
any possibility that he actually won
now this could be because of mail-in
ballots that had
have maybe will not yet be counted as of
november 3rd at midnight that's one
possibility
it could be because of other types of
voter suppression
it could be for any number of different
reasons and i was actually thinking back
to the year 2000 which 2000 was sort of
the first presidential election i paid
close attention to i remember i was in
high school and there were
you know you started to figure out who
are the few right-wing kids
in my very liberal high school and who's
following politics and who's not and
i remember paying close attention to
that election it was bush v gore
and um it came down to florida as many
of you may remember
al gore won the popular vote nationally
ultimately lost
florida and when people think back to
that i was recently talking to people
who misremember the crux of what
happened in the year 2000 in florida
a lot of people correctly remember that
there was a recount started in florida
and that then republican secretary of
state in florida catherine harris got
involved
ultimately the supreme court stopped the
recount
and the state went to george w bush by
about
500 votes and when people think back now
they often think if the supreme court
hadn't stopped the recount
al gore would have won would have won
florida and thus would have won the
presidency
that's not likely the case because
there was a secondary controversy in
florida in the year 2000
the details of which people still argue
about but it was about
votes sent in by mail many from overseas
a bunch of different scenarios a bunch
of different ballots
which were misplaced and thrown out and
just
disappeared okay so the exact details
are less relevant
than the realization that in all
likelihood the recount that was stopped
george w bush was probably going to win
that recount if it had been completed
the real problem was the problem of the
ballots that were not going to be
part of the equation that were that were
gone and
likewise in this upcoming election there
are likely to be a ton of different
layers in the subterfuge including malin
absentee ballots voter suppression
voter purges meddling of different kinds
trump trying to use the judges that he
so famously has
appointed to his advantage on and on and
on and so what hillary clinton
is suggesting is not that if
joe biden loses fair and square he never
concede
what hillary clinton is suggesting is
that until it is really truly all
completely said and done
and it is completely clear that joe
biden has lost
there is no reason for joe biden to
concede now
i think we also have to remember because
people are going crazy pulling their
hair out about over this as if hillary
clinton hillary clinton is saying
something
crazy remember that conceding is merely
a formality it doesn't matter
whether the the losing candidate
concedes
has no bearing on what happens on
january 20th
and when it might come down to lawsuits
and courts and the opinions of judges
maybe judges selected by donald trump
you don't want to do anything the optics
of which might make it easier for a
judge to hand anything to donald trump
and although conceding is merely a
formality
much like running up the score in the
popular vote
these are optics which might provide
cover for a judge to
rule in favor of donald trump if it
comes down to a court
and likewise this is why i've said we
have to run up the popular vote
you know in heavily blue states like
california and massachusetts there
may be leftists who say i'm not going to
vote they don't need my vote or i'll
vote third
party because biden's clearly going to
win california he's clearly going to win
massachusetts i disagree
we have to run up the score make it
harder
for a court to help donald trump in any
way because donald trump is going to use
every tactic possible to steal this
election
joe biden and the democrats need to have
a specific plan for exactly how to deal
with every aspect of this ahead of time
i'm not sure that they do now uh
let's let's deal just for a moment with
what the right wingers are saying again
people like hannity and some right
wingers are reacting
as if hillary clinton is saying even if
you really lose don't concede
that's not what she's saying she's
saying she believes joe biden's going to
win
but that there will be pressure on him
to concede
and foul play such that he might end up
conceding before he's satisfied
that he really lost and that he
shouldn't do that
i'm the first to tell you biden may
actually lose
at least 60 million people are going to
be voting for the re-election of donald
trump
maybe 65 million maybe 66 we don't know
but roughly 60 something million people
will be voting for trump's reelection
it's certainly plausible that trump wins
and if that's the case
uh it's not for joe biden to just insist
that he really won
biden will have to concede and i'm sure
he will and it'll be up to us to deal
with the reality
that we have more than 60 million people
in this country who observed the last
four years
and said give me another four that's a
problem we'll have to deal with and it's
a serious problem
but the advice is correct to joe biden
until you're actually satisfied
that you really lost don't concede and i
hope he follows it
hopefully it won't even be close but
there's a real possibility
that it will be and those close
scenarios as i'm going to talk about
friday are the ones that are going to be
mo
the most difficult legally and also the
most likely to lead to violence in the
streets which i don't want to happen
but i fear is a real possibility if it's
close and trump says that it's rigged
i'll deal with that on friday
uh and what is happening uh in the
intervening time now
is everybody's got to figure out how are
you planning to vote
are you voting absentee if so are you
mailing your ballot or dropping it off
are you voting in person what's the plan
is it going to feel safe
how many masks will you be wearing so on
and so forth that's what we can do in
the intervening time
we will have more on this much more
uh on our instagram page make sure
you're following us there at david
pakman show and also
last night i got a crazy hate mail
and i posted it to my instagram which is
david.pacman
my question to you is do you think the
hate mail i posted last night
is real or fake take a look at it
david.pacman on instagram let me know
what you think